こんにちはーはじめしゃちょーです！！！
今日は
こちら
もうちょっと開いちゃってるんですけども
こちらのだるま落とし
うわー
たくさん！！！
だるま落としを買いました
これもう知らない人いないでしょ
日本の伝統的なおもちゃですからね
こういうふうにだるまを立てて
いきおいよく
だるまの頭を残して、どんどん崩していくやつです
あ、
ゲームオーバー　（真顔
２・４・６・８・１０・２・４・６
17体か...
ちょっと盛ろう...
20個のだるま落としを準備しました
俺は何をするかわかるかみんなー
ただのだるま落としをしても楽しくない
楽しくないことはない
ちょっと面白い
俺は思った
だるま落としをもしものすごい高さでやったら、どうなるのか
なんかねーやっぱね重くなると思うんでー
意外と簡単かもしんない
カンカンカンカンすぐいけるかもしれないですけど
実際にやってみないとわからないんですけども
とりあえずこの１７っ
２０体のだるま落としを使って
すごい高いだるま落としをやってみようと思います
いやあの...
結構胸躍ってます
ではいこう！
とりあえず、頭は全部いらないからー
このドーナツだけをとりあえず重ねて高くしていきましょう
バランスが大事
ここで倒れるようなことがあったらゲームにもならないですからね
とりあえず細心の注意を払わないとやばい
笑　ちょっとまって..
かたがっているよね？
えっ　どこがおかしいんだ？
えっ　でも絶対かたがってるよ
わーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー（真顔
今絶対かたがってたよ
もう一回
バランスが悪い
なんで？
ある程度の高さまではいけるんですけど....
途中までいくとバランスが悪くなっちゃう
あのー
結構職人技ですから
あのこれ
めちゃくちゃ多分すごいと思います
この高さになると基本立たない...............
えっ、まだつむ？
まだつむ？
もうよくね、もう十分だよ
もう1個だけ置いてみようか
もう一個だけ置いてみます
あれ..　あれ？　あれ…　もう　待って　え？
もう一個　もう一個置くか
これ以上乗せるのは無理な気がしてきた
あれ..?
あれ、俺天才かなー？
まあでも
これ以上はまじで無理
これ以上は無理っすねー
もうちょっと頭置かせてください
あああやばいやばい
チッ
いやー難しいよ
さっきのはねかなり奇跡のレベルだったと思う
一回これでやってみるよ！
ひとまず天井目指そう
天井までいけば何かが変わるかもしれない
行ってみようかどうー　・　・　・　（チーン）
あっ、すごくね結構